what's going on guys my name is Everett
homage welcome back to the channel if
you're a regular here
you've probably noticed my background
has changed and that's probably for the
fact that my workplaces
decided to go work from home to help
flatten the curve so basically what
we've done is taken all that
communication and all our computers home
to be able to work remotely off the
cloud now for most people that's a
pretty simple step but for others
meetings are quite important and that's
one of the predominant reasons where
this video has come from today what
we're going to be looking at is three
different video platforms to help you
guys continue running your business and
communicating with your loved ones
during this covert 19 pandemic so we're
gonna be looking at zoom Skype and WebEx
so let's start with zoom zoom is one of
the up-and-comers in this space it's
been around for a couple years now and
it is definitely one of the easiest
platforms from all three to use if
you're being invited into a zoom meeting
you can access that meeting from
absolutely n device including an
old-school telephone so if somebody
sends you a series of numbers to type in
to your keypad you can easily connect to
a conference call if all we have access
to is a telephone device however what we
are looking at is well here is video
conferencing because video conferencing
is very important in 2020 zoom Skype and
WebEx actually all record in HD video
now you might be thinking well we're
ready at the 4k video and the s20 ultra
records in a k so why aren't we actually
recording in 4k and streaming in 4k now
the reason I haven't picked any video
conferencing platforms of strength above
HD is because the more people that work
from home the more stress we have
and our bandwidth so stranding in HD
actually isn't a bad thing per se if
your individual looking for a one-on-one
conference or potentially a medium-sized
company of looking at to host up to
forty nine video screens at the same
time zoom is perfect for you it also
gives you the ability to teleconference
in a total of 1,000 people on their
premium enterprise paid package the free
version of zoom actually only allows you
a hundred people in the teleconference
which is actually a pretty huge number
for a free platform if you're looking to
run webinars training sessions classroom
education style videos or anything of
those sorts sue is the perfect platform
here it allows virtual hand raising of
all your participants so you can easily
find out who needs to say something and
when it also gives you a whole bunch of
analytical data afterwards that you can
review if you want to another great
feature here is it has interactive polls
and questions and answers so if you're
hosting a webinar for example or a class
you can easily post the Q&A and get a
whole bunch of feedback very quickly and
very effectively to move forward with
that webinars if you want to keep a
record of the teleconference or
videoconference you can easily record
and save straight to your hard drive or
to the cloud if you want to you can also
share your screen directly with
individuals if you need them to see
something on your screen one of the
downsides of zoom is you can only host a
40-minute videoconference with the free
version you can host up to 24 hours if
you're willing to pay 20 dollars 99
cents Australian per month for the
professional version one thing I almost
forgot with zoom is the simple fact that
if you're an e-commerce entrepreneur and
you want to start selling some classes
or some webinars or some sort of
information on a regular basis you can
set up a registration fee with zoom so
you can invite a whole bunch of people
to come and watch this webinar or
seminar that you're hosting and for
example charge them a five dollar
registration fee so all of a sudden
you've made a business out of zoom
moving onto skype now
is very similar to the zoom platform
however unlike zoo you can't access it
anywhere without an account if you want
to use Skype you do need the app
installed or a user somehow in some way
shape or form this limits you to being
somewhat technologically savvy to be
able to create a Skype account and set
something out and then invite somebody
into a chat it is a little bit of a
complex process and it isn't as easy as
oome so that's definitely a draw down
for Skype you can have up to 50 people
on a teleconference or a videoconference
on skype which is a little bit less than
zoom but it doesn't give you the same
abilities of recording your screen
sharing your screen questions and
answers and a couple polls here and
there one of the other benefits of Skype
is privacy along with having encrypted
conversations which all of them have its
standard it also gives you the ability
to blur out the background so if you're
sitting at home with your kids running
around in the background or if your
environment is a little bit less
professional than you'd like it to be
you can easily blur out the background
to make sure nobody sees what's going on
and I think the best feature that Skype
has is a real-time live translator so if
I was here speaking to you in a
completely different language you could
have a little text line at the bottom of
your screen directly translating into
you in real-time so if you for example
had a cousin in Germany that you wanted
to wish a happy birthday you could use
Skype to communicate with them very
effectively and very quickly Scott does
also have Skype business which is now
called Microsoft teams but I'm not gonna
dive into that too much because it isn't
cross-compatible across all platforms
and you really want to be able to use
something it doesn't matter who you're
talking to if there are an iPhone and
Android a old smartphone a tablet
whatever and you want to be able to use
that software
moving on to WebEx and if you haven't
heard of WebEx before that's okay
because women is targeted at your
premium enterprises with millions of
dollars to spend on this sort of stuff
but that doesn't mean
everybody can't use it so WebEx can host
up to a hundred thousand people on the
same teleconference at any given time
that's more people than I know in this
world and probably more people that
actually met throughout my whole
lifetime face-to-face and had a
conversation with that hundred thousand
people is limited to twenty five videos
on its screen which is again more than
enough for those people just like zoom
WebEx is able to run a whole bunch of
different platforms you can record your
screen share your screen questions and
answers' polls ecommerce related
webinars and seminars where you charge
people to watch your content and
basically everything that zoom can do
where WebEx goes over and above is a
simple fact
again it is targeted at these larger
enterprises that have millions of
dollars to spend so it hosts its own
products and platforms that you can
purchase later on down the track if you
want so if you wanted a whiteboard
dedicated to drawing and sharing alive
during a webinar then you can buy a
WebEx whiteboard and share that directly
it's a physical whiteboard it's
something tangible that you can use
during these seminars they also produce
their own at video screens video cameras
and microphones to make your meeting
rooms that little bit more special and a
little bit more professional
so to recap I think zoom is probably the
best for all users who are just looking
to start a video conference Skype is
probably more your medium-sized business
that wants to limit it to individuals
within their company and just use it as
a platform to chat basically you can do
it absolutely everything you can do on
skype and that you can do on zoo so if
you already set up on skype just that on
skype there isn't too many added
benefits in zoo for anybody up to a
hundred participants in that
conversation and finally WebEx I think
is for the top dogs out there the guys
that have millions of dollars to throw
at this and it really invests heavily
into it if this is something you're
doing on a regular basis and it isn't
just because of the code of 19 per
Demick then I think WebEx is something
to actually look into and invest your
money into that's all from me today guys
I hope you enjoyed this special edition
that brought on by the kerbin 19
pandemic if you did and want more tech
reviews of all sorts of different tech
products from mobile phones to laptops
to everything in between make sure you
smash that subscribe button
20:20 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday